in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion, for May 29th, on which we commemorate the holy martyr
Theodosia of Constantinople, Saint Theodosia was the daughter of noble and wealthy Christians
in Constantinople.
After her father's death when she was seven, she followed her mother, who had decided
to retire to a monastery in the capital, where the girl grew in piety and the love of God.
On her mother's death, she gave her fortune away to the poor, keeping only what was necessary
for three icons, of Christ, the mother of God, and Saint Anastasia.
And then became a nun.
Two years later, Emperor Leo III unleashed his persecution of those who venerated the holy
icons and deposed the holy patriarch Yermannus, who had refused to submit to his decrees.
When he ordered that the icon over the bronze door be removed, Theodosia, who was present
with other devout people, urged by holy indignation, rushed forward and overset the ladder, up
on which the Emperor's agent had climbed, and he fell to his death.
The group of confessors then moved to the Patriarchate, meaning to stone the heretic
patriarch Anastasius.
On the Emperor's order, the soldiers then seized the insurgents to execute them.
One of them brutally threw Saint Theodosia to the ground, dragged her to the place known
as the bull, and furiously thrust a ram's horn through her throat.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.